in the escape from tarkov alpha kills
comes flow and that's an important part
of its recipe for great gun fights the
hardcore first-person shooter is shaping
up to be a tense and entertaining
experience with some awesome mechanics
to boot these are the four things under
the hood that you should definitely know
about escape from tarkov number one the
lube lead players start with a stash of
gear currently a one-time purchase for
real money and then they build and equip
a loadout before each mission but
there's a catch if the player dies their
equipment is gone this is currently
mitigated by a safe box called a gamma
container it's in the players inventory
and this is where a small amount of loot
can be retained on death the one we were
given for this preview had just enough
space for a pistol and some valuable
items and if you're playing the Alpha
make sure you stash items in that don't
lose box you can get dangerously low on
gear to the point where you no longer
stand a chance we thought as Manifest in
a number of matches with bare-bones
players at the start of each round
they'd all go to the same storage yard
and fight over the same weapon and
that's before the main mission even
started an offline mode can currently be
used for gear farming so go there if
you've run out and can't compete you can
also visit a number of specialized
vendors to buy and sell loot guns
backpacks or some of that delectable
condensed milk number 2 the gun gamble
escape from tarkov 10 gun sights and
lows between them are nail-biting but
you don't necessarily want to bring your
best gun to every fight some rounds you
may want to rebuild your arsenal and
only gamble losing a pistol when you die
selling gun attachments for night vision
goggles meds water or keys it could also
be a much more prosperous bet and if you
think your Luck's about to run out you
may want to stash valuable ammo in your
safe box as quickly as you can a chance
of losing a great gun adds pension and
player investment to each round and
really makes you care about every moment
number 3 the fun in the details
one of our favorite moments from the
Alpha so far was running around the
factory trying to figure out why a life
is chasing us we honestly thought it was
a bug until we realized we had scavenged
a flashlight from a body and didn't turn
it off that could have gone badly these
details also manifest in gunfights with
great ballistics convincing glass on
optics different ammo types and the
ability to unload and reload bullets
from magazines checking your chamber for
a round even reduces the chances of your
weapon jamming number four the tactics
the most developed mission so far is the
customs level players start in the same
area and can either shoot it out or work
together honestly though they usually
just shoot it out and that's just the
beginning
smart players avoid the first clash and
then purposely trail a group of players
in the hopes that they clear their way
to the exit or they go ahead and set up
ambushes to score better gear side areas
filled with the potential for rare loot
are also present but you'll need to grab
keys from the vendors to get to them so
pacing of this raid feels good and the
game understands that confrontations
have a lot more tension when they're
spaced out and unpredictable it's too
early to tell how the final build of
tarkov will shape up with just the three
missions available in its alpha
ultimately balancing the loop lead will
make or break this experience which
player is able to pay real money for a
larger secure container there's a risk
of loot rich players having an unfair
advantage or worse people falling off
the loot ladder and walking away the
tactical aspects of tarkov are a lot of
fun and the risk reward tension of
building and losing load outs is great
at getting you invested in staying alive
we'll keep playing as things progress so
stay tuned to gain people on all of our
escape from tarkov coverage
you
[Music]